we heard rumors about Jurassic world 3
that maybe Laura Dern and Sam O'Neil
will return or the chicken people what
are the chances that we can get you back
on the franchise would you be down down
if I was any further down I'd be me all
the way in China happy Chris Pratt I
have to tell you you and dance eternal
money's motivation at southern decadence
gave me life I mean like the I did did
you I did yeah it did that was part of
that was a great LGBTQ parade down in
New Orleans I had to spend much time
there before but but we were down there
that was part of that show that I'm
doing the world according to Jeff
Goldman comes out November 12 on Disney
Plus that was a great day I had a grand
grand time I'd never been in a parade
before like that I for a second Idol
that was at the head of the parade and
then I found myself not as part of the
itinerary up there on one of those you
know French border little balconies and
all I'm having a moment you know I just
had a moment they caught it I didn't
even know they were catching it had you
heard that song before nor mommy's
motivation I can't say on the playlist
now it is you don't know that song she
doesn't I apologize for her she doesn't
keep up with the kids I've been telling
her Thompson Twins Twisted Sister all
the new groups III I'll tell her about I
believe you me I'll keep her a breast
well she must be a big fan of your music
and I know you have some new stuff
coming what can you tease I can tease
all sorts of things it comes out
November 1st it's on Decca Records the
mildred Schnitzer Orchestra is with me
once again with some unbelievable
certain stellar editions we've got guest
singers on it some of whom have been
announced so I'm not telling tales if I
tell you about Sharon Bennett our single
with her let's face the music and dance
came out yesterday you could go and get
it you know who else is on it Fiona
we announced it yesterday so it's no
secret but I'm so cool
unbelievably Stiller and Inara George
and Hannah Calvi and then there are a
couple other Geena saputo and then there
are a couple and I sing a song believe
it or not yeah so you're on there too
great and then there are a couple other
surprise singers that you have no idea
about yet but you'll remember this
moment yes I'm thinking of it I'm not
telling you but you'll remember this
blink if it's Beyonce and bling
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]